you
[Music]
so what we are going to talk about today
we are we were working on recently at
Prezi
this is basically the evolution of the
or data ingestion and instrumentation
platform but before starting with that I
would like to demonstrate for you in a
simple way what's the problem we try to
tackle so because we are after lunch so
I just give you some easy question so if
you want to do some analysis or training
your model was the most fundamental
thing what you need data so if you have
data that's half success if you have
data in the right format that's a luxury
so I don't believe you that you have
everything on the correct format so if
you want to put your data in a correct
format to work with usually you write
some kind of transformation if you want
to run the transformation everyday then
you build some kind of ETI job how you
get the ETL job you get some kind of
sample data you try to check the sample
data for all the edge cases like this is
your ETA job you have all the inputs
here so you are very well prepared if
any kind of data is coming you should be
able to push into this box and then you
create your ETA jobs usually you want
some kind of historical data so you want
to run back for months or years and this
is what usually happens so you start run
your back field and you get some data
and it goes into the box cool so
everything is working fine then you have
some other data actually you can see it
won't fit in the box but there is some
other shape even though it's not the
same shape but you still can process so
this is so cool the ETL pipeline won't
stop it still can process even though
maybe there will be later some issue
with data but you are fine so it's one
block you and what usually happen
then there is a shape which coming like
this one which won't fit anywhere so
what what you can do and then actually
this is when your data pipeline here
will fail and you get some kind of alert
if you're a data engineers so we really
hate this issue so usually what you do
because you have some kind of time scrum
constant because your ETL job should
have finished already
you're just hack so you just put in the
box and we don't really like to hang
because the next time you will do
backfill on the same dataset this will
happen again so this is what we show you
what we did to not happen is with us
that often but who we are I'm not sure
if everyone knows what is Prezi do you
know what is pressing that's cool so
it's a couple of hands there so
basically it's a presentation software
what we are using so it's very easy to
tell you what it is but who we are
actually
we Presley we have offices in Budapest
San Francisco and Riga we have more than
100 million registered users and we have
3 more than 3.5 billion creative presses
so far and these desires still
increasing but you are I guess you are
most interested in what the data so at
Prezi our data is usually some kind of
clicks in data from the application but
we are collecting from Eddy other
various sources but now we are going to
talk about the product and what kind of
data we collect from the product and
this is what we have currently in our
code storage is around 200 bytes of data
and we increase this number and one
terabyte per day okay but what's the
data stream so you would saying that we
have a huge data team actually the data
team is basically a handful of people
who are the data engineers
and some other nice guys who are the
eternal East and data scientists and who
uses the data as you can see at Prezi
even security finance so basically the
whole company is using our product or
data for various reasons and I will pass
this and to get thank you so gentlemen
now that you know where we are coming
from let's embark on a journey as if we
were a piece of data in presence of data
infrastructure but before we do so let
me tell you a bit about our problems and
for the sake of possible for the sake of
positivity
let's call em challenges the ones that
we had to overcome during this project
so the approach that we had in the past
is that we should log each and every
possible user interaction and technical
event what happens in the product I
don't know if you have ever tried to
find a needle in a haystack but as an
analyst it was kind of a death scenario
so getting to any result or conclusion
was pretty time-consuming and hard also
we thought we had an understanding of
what kind of data that we have but
reality was something else so we had a
catalog where we stored each or each of
our logs
political events but this catalog did
not match reality and it's as an analyst
I was facing the situation and a lot of
times that I thought that I know what
the definition of an event is what kind
of format I should expects a certain
attribute should be a string or an
integer what's the name of the event and
then it was not the case in reality so
you have to dig deep and understand what
your data is otherwise you don't get the
right result for sure and also there
were a lot of events that were flowing
into our systems that we didn't know
they existed
because they were not defined or safety
in this low catalogue let me tell you
about a funny example once I had to
define a new event late for some kind of
a user facing feature I don't know maybe
uploading an image to your presentation
and then I wanted to add a nice little
error message as an attribute to that
event so if that happens what the what
was the exact error message now I looked
up error in this fancy log catalog that
I mentioned you earlier and there were
27 different types of error fields I
could choose from not very good I wasn't
sure if I should choose the error which
is a string or the other error which is
a string and one of the example values
is in no licence found maybe it should
be integer or another string hello so it
was kind of crazy and messy even
defining new events then we had our real
time live logs in a central machine so
if you were not familiar and friends
with bash then you were not able to
access them which caused kind of issues
because you saw that there were a lot of
there are a lot of people in the present
organization who came to use our data
and sometimes we have to check with them
stuff also there was a lack of quality
checks so it happened that one of the
product teams for example changed the
name of a log or changed string figures
to integer and then our ETA pipeline
broke just couldn't handle it we
expected something as there and that's
the better of the issues because in the
other case what can happen is that your
ETA pipeline progress is fine but you
still miss some data because obviously
the format change you will not not parse
that data these situations are the most
frightening ones because these lead to
misleading analysis and skewed results
usually our stakeholders are not so
happy about that if we find this out so
I think you get it that the
importance of understanding and and
cleaning data was huge and this took up
most of our times people hear about like
we spend 80 percent of our time cleaning
the era in the industry that was kind of
about right at Prezi as well but that's
one thing the the bad consequence of
this is that we were spending a lot of
time on it and it it increased our like
time to two inside unfortunately so now
that you know like the field in which we
were in the situation in which we were
like a eunuch or so now let's talk about
our amazing cross-functional teams and
what our aim was really when when
starting to touch this whole process at
the birth of data we had a company-wide
project under the codename glass box and
if you remember Thomas is little
demonstration in the beginning let's
imagine that you can see through that
box so it's glass well that was the
state that we wanted to achieve to be
able to understand how our users prezis
users are using our product and to draw
conclusions fast and accurately
thankfully we had support from both the
management and from anyone consuming or
wanting to but not able to to consume
data so from bottom and up it definitely
had a lot during those weeks and months
when we were dividing the whole product
because what it meant is that we had to
throw away everything we had and start
from scratch
now if you mention it to any software
engineer there probably will not be
happy about it nor will any product
manager or data analyst either but we
had a couple of goals and value
propositions for our project so of
course the main goal was to reduce the
time to insight and conclusions a lot
and I tell you buddy
our exact results a bit later we also
wanted to
improve the quality and the consistency
of our locks we have so you can create a
presentation or modify presentation
online on the web in a browser you have
I mean we have mac and windows apps as
well native apps there's viewer on iOS
and Android so we have a lot of
platforms and these logs should be
consistent across stitch across these
platforms and we also wanted to empower
more parts of the organization to use
data and leverage the power that lies
there
it shouldn't we wanted to avoid the
situation when someone but when only
someone with Python or sequel competence
can access and and get insights from our
data and so we were thinking about a
couple of new tools to empower more
parts of the organization to to use data
and as a member of the data science
analytics team we wanted to achieve a
shift in our focus so we wanted to we
wanted to get away from the garbage in
garbage out kind of scenarios and we
introduced a couple of processes and
quality checks on the data for this I'm
gonna talk about that a second we wanted
to spend less time on cleaning the data
the raw data and on maintaining our
eightieth pipeline if something changed
and also it was a funny situation when
you first get some kind of results and
then you were wondering like is it
really that's like we had to increase
the trust in our own data to be able to
move fast and these kind of situations
we were hoping that would lead to a
shift to more like deep dive analysis
and modeling from a lot of ad hoc
questions that we had to to answer and
we were hoping that the tools that we
are introducing will have both like
software engineers and like product
people to to answer their questions
pretty fast without the half of the data
science analytics team so one of the
things that we introduced one of the
processes and this is the key for
practice
intention for us he lives under the name
log management which is not low
catalogued as the past now we have lot
management it's way better and this is
this depict actually an enforced review
process so you were not able to add any
new product analytical event to the
system you were not able to code it
either if it didn't get an approval in
log management
so let's imagine that we are like
product people and we want to implement
instrument a new product feature what do
we do first
we have to define what the actual flow
of that feature is so there should be a
visual representation like a series of
screenshots this is the click flow as we
call it available to the whole company
so if someone from marketing wants to
understand what's going on in product
they have a document where they can go
through the flow and understand what are
the actual places were we instrumented
something and we also introduced the the
term job story loop which is basically a
fancy funnel which allows people to skip
or exit the the the funnel at certain
points and then come back and continue
all over again this is more like a user
based approach to analysis than the
session or over total event counts etc
then the next thing naming convention
now that we have we and we know what we
want to instrument and how the feature
looks like we have kik streams click
close and we have all the names and the
actions that we want to instrument there
has to be certain rules that we have to
follow in order for everyone to
understand what that specific action is
that we are instrument in for so I'll
give you one example in the bottom right
corner you can open the presentation
editor from many different parts of the
product everywhere we should call it
open editor then this depicts user
intent so we look it at the click and
not when it happened why because we have
another event
loaded editor sits in bus stands it's in
simple past because there's like a time
that lapses between the two usually and
that people might be interested in the
distribution of these across platforms
different computers browsers etc and
also that's more of a technical event
that's not something the user user did
it's us
Prezi providing them with the editor
actually loading so these are the
technical events and for example you
shouldn't build your active time
calculation based on solely technical
events because if the user does not
interact with the product they are not
really active are they and the third
thing is that events and the information
attached to those events should be
universal across platforms no matter if
I open this editor in on tomash is that
book or in the browser it should provide
me I mean all the events should have the
same name and all the the fields like
server datum user ID etc should be
following the same definition and the
same format on each platform and also as
I mentioned earlier there has to be an
approval before before developers can
touch this and actually instrument it
later on so this is like a valuable
piece of the process itself there's a
select loop of admins we call them Lords
of the logs as I think about almost like
Lord of the Rings you know so in a bit
of gamified way we try to incentivize
people to to talk about the
instrumentation practices how they think
about the feature that they were an
instrument or of which they want to
change or modify the instrumentation etc
so people should usually speak in person
and and discuss what are the the things
that they want to achieve and the this
admin group is responsible for keeping
consistency across the whole product
avoid situations when there's 27
different error messages and Jessie does
you just don't know what to do with them
so this was our process part and
to my back to Thomas yeah so all of
these things are worth nothing if you
it's only lives in this log management
tool and you are not validating or
enforcing it so first we decided how to
store this kind of event description and
we decided to choose the Avro schema
format because it's very easy to work
with that over--oh for what itself is
very widespread in the big data world
and actually a schema revolution is part
of the format so because we decided to
use that it was the logical decision to
generate schema from this log management
and store it in complaint schema
registry so we did not have to reinvent
the wheel but use an existing open
source tool but to be honest we are not
just generating one schema but we are
generating schema for every platform and
why we are doing that because maybe you
can see what I will tell you more
because like in mobile the device ID is
mandatory but you if you are not coming
from mobile but you are coming from a
web that you won't have device ID but
somehow we wanted to make different
differentiate between the platforms and
then forcing these rules for per
platform per platform so that's why we
did so maybe you can see there but I see
in that example you can see that schema
there the platform named as desktop so
this is the schema which should come
from the desktop and if the desk and if
the events which coming from the desktop
there the string is not desktop we want
let them in and also as you can see
there is the device edit which is a
mandatory attribute for this schema and
this way we could enforce for the test
or platform that it should send in the
device ID on the other hand so we have
all of this scheme of per platform but
in the end we want to collect all of
these locks into one event stream so
that's why we come up with the idea of a
loose Kyra well basically all of the
fields which are
mandatory only per platform level those
are here will be more like optional so
as you can see in a Louis schema level
device ID will be optional even though
it was on platform level and then that
would and later on you will see how we
validate with that and as you can see
there type of platforms so these events
can come from desktop web or mobile so
all of three are there and actually one
other difference here we are not using
enum values because in if you are using
Inghams in aggro that can and if you try
to add or remove new enum values that
can break the compatibility and what we
want to achieve is basically on platform
specific level we have no computer code
compatibility check so you can just do
whatever you want but on the loop schema
level VM force full schema compatibility
to previous versions so in that way you
can do such a change you just change
something from string to integer so it
can't happen and thus get mentioned we
could convince the management to work on
this project but one thing is harder
convincing the management is convincing
your developers to using this system
luckily we could reach out to various
teams for from all of the platforms so
we use people from all the platforms we
had the champions who actually created
as the case for us what does it mean so
if you have the schema in the schema
registry then you have some kind of tool
for all of the platforms so for Mac iOS
Android etc and they are basically based
on the schemas you can generate code so
in the end when you want to log some
kind of event the developers don't have
to manually craft these events but
basically they have some kind of like
some kind of function like insert image
event and in that
he or she only need to define those
properties which is which are even
specific because all of the rest like
the times like device ID etc comes from
the SD case or the developers can use in
that way it's very convenient for the
developers to use and they don't want to
use some other things because it's very
easy to work with that and on the other
hand we will get valid events and when
they check the schema and we release a
new version to a web or to desktop that
they start sending in the logs we have a
locking endpoint why we have a locking
endpoint because we don't fully trust
what's coming from the user right like
client time you can trust really your
clients machines time what it shows so
usually we had the server time we had
the user ID from the user so we don't
trust in an event and we basically
enrich those events at our logging
endpoint and after that as you can see a
bottom left a top left corner there is a
server so from the service we don't
expect to send through or log in Ian
point because we trust in them and they
can direct this sent to a log stash why
we are using log stash because it was
pretty convenient for us to use to
building a log stash codec which
basically gets from the confluence
screen schema registry registry the lose
and the suite schema do the validation
converting to a format which is a
message which comes from the client and
basically sending to elastic storage and
Cabana so this is the way how you can
see the live stream and live data stream
and we are storing there for a couple of
days the data and we also send to Kafka
but we only send took of got the valued
event so if there is some issue with
with your event
it goes to Cabana there you can check
the error but we and we put in a
separate Kafka topic but we want that in
a directory and in Kafka be
have an ambulance stream per event I'd
so basically there as I mentioned use
the new schema to convert all of the
platform specific message into one
format and things and sending to a Kafka
topic but we don't stop there because we
want to ship those information to s3
barely using another open-source tool I
called Apache Goblin and I will show you
what we do there when we from getting
the data from Kafka and moving to s3 we
do a couple of transformation like
flattening the data so we use
hierarchical data in our events but
usually if you have hierarchical data it
can cause issues even if you are using
hive or if you want to load some kind of
other data store so that's why we are
flattening the events after we flatten
the event basically remove some kind of
PII information and we do some like we
reach the IP address and we do geoip
lookup for the events and then a couple
of hours later so which put these
messages into staging and a couple of
hours later we do our job which which is
compact the data and also the duplicate
so in this application means there is
some kind of duplicate event we just
remove and compaction I mean that if you
have multiple applies storing on s3
then we just compact into one file
because it's whether if you are
careening through hive or whatever to
have last file than more so it's always
close the problem if you have a bunch of
files at any few ship data from Kafka I
usually have the number of partitions
of files on s3 and after the data
application if we see that some data
arrived after the previous compaction we
put into some kind of lid older why it's
important because it can happen that or
nightly they are already finished and
there is some kind of data for that Dave
and that ETL was run and and then
because based on the late events we can
decide if we want to reprocess the whole
ETA pipeline which needed that data or
we just drop those events so it's really
up to us because it can cause some kind
of so analysts can ask questions or even
a management when they can see that hey
why the data changed for yesterday
because I I just rerun my DTI jobs so we
don't want to that and then we start
storing honestly you know partition
format as you can see there is a date
and our partition and we also register
in to hide metal store Andy for the
schema with the latest ever schema this
was a couple of weeks before then
decided to remove the Raleigh partition
because it was too much overhead and we
don't really need that so we just moved
away from that and again and now finally
other people as well can touch the data
not just the awesome data engineering
team so let's see a bit about our
results these numbers are more like
estimates of mine but rather accurate I
think so for example you can see that
the with the red line time to insight
rapidly and radically decreased over
time also the self-service customers of
data grew so we have literally more than
100 people now in a company of 300 using
our solutions and also the time spent on
cleaning data decreased a lot so we
don't have to always get down to the
bottom of mmm is that really the format
this field should be or Nauticus should
be evident that is we have proper
quality alerts and quality checks on top
of the incoming data as well so what did
this project mean for the data science
team we have better utilized resources
we spent that way last time on on
cleaning data we have a lot less
interrupts which is something that makes
me really happy
you know you can attend the like tank
context which is during a day and still
be productive so with the help of some
of our the tools that I'm going to talk
about in a minute have had reduced the
number of interrupt occurs even business
stakeholders can can answer their own
questions pretty easily and also we
thanks to this we kind of shifted to a
more more strategic lower role in the
company's landscape what does it mean
for the company we have or everyone has
better access to data as Thomas
mentioned we have Cubana where you can
get instant feedback on the thing that
you just implemented or instrumented and
also if you think that there's like
weird issue going on maybe a prior one
then you can quickly check and see if
there's if the looks prove your theory
or not we have a patch it's appalling
sorry this was a quick picture from a
screenshot off of Cubana and also we
have a patch it's Apple in as our
notebook that we use and this is used by
mostly the data team and software
engineers obviously because you have to
write code to get anything out of it but
we also have indicative which is like a
drag-and-drop solution which you can
analyze user journeys pretty fast pretty
smoothly this is like one random example
that I creativity within like a minute
all the stakeholders from a business
background he was it a lot and it's much
better if someone has an idea of like
okay I had the question this is I think
the answer can someone just buddy that
if I did this drag and drop thingy the
right way then it takes you like two
seconds or something like that to
validate that so it was really helpful
for us also we increased data
transparency so we have those quick
flows and Experian shots I mentioned you
before and we have this log management
tool where the descriptions of each
event are filled and you know where you
can expect those we store some meta
information as well on what like GS a
job story loop they belong to so if you
are interested in image insertion then
there's like 20 different events but
actually and then you can filter for
only those and see but what what you can
cook with basically for your analysis
and we as I mentioned I think a couple
of times but I'm really proud of it is
definitely Chris the time to inside we
decreased the time in which our data in
a proper format gassed to a data
warehouse and we can catch bugs in
logging pretty fast so if something
changed or if something's not working we
were there too we will be there to hold
down the people who can guess all that
and how much is gonna finish the
presentation with a couple of next steps
yeah and actually so we still work to do
so like not all of the part as we said
we basically we instrumented the whole
product but not the whole so we are
still have a bunch of place where we
still need to reinstall and so this is
work ahead and also we would like to
extend this system to not just support
and aleca analytical loads but also
developer logs for like even we have use
cases where they basically use these
pipelines
measure how the continuous integration
system works and like how long does it
take to build an app etc and of course
because we have business Kafka and
everything has a nice schema we would
like to extend the real-time usage
because even from marketing there is a
branch of need that they want to like do
some kind of real time triggers for our
users and we do really sing and actually
there are a few use cases for that that
with the addi system you can very easily
introduce such real real time three
girls into the and just like a final
thought so these are not only next steps
we are actively working on each so if
you're interested we are happy to talk
about any of them in the following
office hour that we'll have and if you
have I do hope to do that so thank you
very much for attention yeah I thank you
for the talk that was very relevant for
us to hear as well one thing I was
curious about is how did maybe you said
it but how do you measure the time to
insight or has that just user feedback
or so I didn't yet measure it exactly
that's why I said it's rather an
estimate but I did look at our like JIRA
board and I did look at the threads that
we have in our data Channel and slack
and they're the and I know cuz I'm
sometimes a data magnate who has to
answer all the interrupts and I know
that it decreased like really very close
like we at least half the time on
average for the forties these questions
that came in so because we have like
indicative as I mentioned and separate
as well so both like software engineers
and product people can try to come up
with something as an answer for them for
themselves we have regular trainings to
for for these tools so they can attend
and the next time they can do it better
or they can start to do it
and this led to two people actually
trying to answer the questions I'm not
just saying like what's the distribution
of browsers for last week like you can
go there and check and then we can
validate if your query was right or not
that's way less effort from our side and
these things had a lot so that's why it
was a conservative estimation that we at
least half the time of time to inside
and actually I think that was one of the
best feedback when one of the founder
actually by himself created charts and
we're looking some kind of insights
without the help of an analyst hey
thanks for a great presentation if you
want slide back when you have that data
architecture you're great
how do you deploy keep this consistent
what do you keep the consistency in the
whole in whole architecture what do you
have different like code blocks being
deployed in different places that you
show the way that you're ingesting
things into astray like us to mean but
there are like many moving parts in the
whole and to enter key tech chure and I
was wondering how you make an intent
deployment and how you keep everything
you know working properly
yeah I think most of these blocks can be
deployed individually without causing
any issues generally don't really have
any specific process witness infra as I
think very trying to move northward
towards the kubernetes world and I think
there will be more crafted way to deploy
so I guess but we don't really have any
specific process to do this
you
[Music]